Okay.
Thank you very much for,
for coming this afternoon and thanks
to Louise and Google food talks for
inviting me to speak. So, um,
I'm going to talk to you a
little bit about Orthorexia. Um,
any of you have any
idea what Orthorexia is?
Some of you are nodding some saying
no, not so sure. What, what would you,
what would you say Orthorexia wars.
What was your kind of,
what's your kind of definitely
the obsession with helping
you. Yeah, pretty much.
You've pretty much hit the
nail on the head there. It's
exactly what it is. So, um,
so yeah, it is, it's, I think
it's a really interesting topic.
It's a fairly new term.
Um,
it was only sort of brought to our
attention in 1996 when Steve Brotman,
um, he's, uh, a physician in, in the
states kind of identified it as a,
as an issue with a lot of his clients
who were kind of trying to be healthy.
But I'd almost be quite at the
point where it was obsessive.
So when you break down Orthorexia is it
is basically the obsession with being
pure of eating correctly
is the exact term. Um,
and I think it's come about because there
are so many kind of ideas around what
healthy is.
So it kind of like one of my questions
to you is what does it actually mean to
be healthy in 2017? I mean,
what, what are your thoughts?
Know I asked this whenever I do workshops
and I do workshops with schools,
with athletes, with coaches, um,
with school nurses a lot as well because
they do a lot of work around disordered
eating and sort of poor
relationships with food.
It's really interesting what comes back.
So I'd love to know what you think
healthy eating is or what health,
what it means to be healthy in,
in 2017.
Yup,
Yep. Yeah. I love the fact that
you've picked up on the term balance.
We'll go back to that at some point.
Anybody else want to add anything else?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah. And I think one of the things I
want to make really clear here is, um,
sometimes people get the wrong idea
about what I'm trying to promote.
I am a Dietitian, so I do promote
a very healthy way of eating,
which does mean majority to lots of fruit,
vegetables,
whole grains actually in line with some
of the things that you do here at Google.
So it is,
it is what I promote.
What I want to bring to the attention
here is the actually sometimes in some
people we can get a little bit extreme.
And when it becomes extreme,
it starts to affect your
health and your mental health.
That's when it becomes a problem. And
that's what I'm seeing more and more of.
And so that's kind of what I want
to talk about today. So, yeah.
So one of the challenges I have as a
practitioner is that there were so many
messages about food. I'm sure every
single day you pick up your phone,
you look at magazines and there's always
something new. What should we eat?
Who should be follow?
What should we do?
And obviously while I'm a
big fan of social media,
I think it do lots of really positive
things and get some really positive
messages out there.
I'm also slightly nervous of it because
I think it creates influences that don't
always give us the right messages.
So I mean these are just a few.
I'm sure you know all of
these people. Um, and,
and I struggle with this because
on that page, on that slide,
there's not a single person who is
actually qualified to give out nutritional
advice.
So from my point of view,
when you are putting stuff out on
Instagram or you're doing blogs or you're
writing articles,
you're writing books,
even actually you're kind of
giving some misinformation and,
and the problem comes,
not to, majority of us,
majority of us can read something and
go, yeah, I'll take a bit of that,
but I'm going to forget about that.
That's okay.
The problem comes when you
are somebody that may be,
is a little bit susceptible to developing
a poor relationship with food. Um,
and again, I will go through
what that would look like.
So I guess some of the big trends that
are come out of the last few years, um,
eat clean, I think we all hear about
that is always hashtag he clean.
That's the big thing.
It's almost like a badge of honor.
I mean the number of of athletes and
clients that have come see me and they're
like, I always eat clean and they're
really excited about the fact that they're
actually saying that to me. And I'm
like, okay. And then really a bit like,
well you don't seem impressed. And
I'm like, well what does that mean?
What does eat clean actually mean?
Because from my point of view,
if I don't follow your rules,
then somehow it makes me feel like I'm
eating dirty, which I know I don't.
So for me,
labeling and terms and hashtags,
while they're brilliant and useful,
these things can be really quite,
they can be quite detrimental to a
lot of people. Um, so eating clean,
green juices, superfoods, these are
all things we hear about all the time.
And I am not for one second saying that
you shouldn't have a green juice and you
shouldn't eat foods that
are seem to be super.
Although I don't ever believe in a
particular one. Food being super,
it's more about your collection of foods
that then gives you a balanced diet and
all the nutrients you need.
In the same way,
I don't demonize any foods because I
don't believe one food group alone or one
food is what is going to cause
you negative health problems.
So some of the common misconceptions,
sugar,
let's talk about sugar.
What do we know about sugar?
What do we hear about sugar?
Anyone want to tell me what they
yeah,
yeah, yeah, yeah. But then
you've got those sugars,
like fruit, sugars, stuff like that.
So, but your main conception of it,
as soon as you hear, should we go
straight to the bathroom? Yeah.
Yeah. Really, really, really good answer.
And the thing is for me is
that I think it's just been,
it's been blown out of
as well because again,
we have bloggers and influencers who
talk about refined sugar free and sugar
free cakes.
But then you look at the recipes and
they're full of maple syrup and coconut
sugar and that it somehow
is deemed healthier.
But actually the end of the day sugar
is sugar. Whether it is molasses, honey,
white sugar,
maple syrup.
And one of my biggest kind of challenges
to some of the bloggers and I have been
on stage with one. Um, but
I won't go there and um,
is the actually the end of the day
you say that white sugar is processed.
Well it's no different to removing the
SAP from coconut to make coconut sugar is
exactly the same process.
There was no difference.
So you cannot say the sugar,
you know,
white table sugar is processed and coconut
sugar isn't cause at the same thing.
Biggest thing about all of it though is
that they all give you the same amount
of energy per hundred grams and they
all are used in the body in exactly the
same way. The body cannot dif,
you know, cannot kind of go,
oh this is coconut sugar is better
for me so I'm going to use it.
And this way it doesn't,
it just literally breaks it down.
Uses it in the same way.
If you eat any product to access any
product to access of what your body needs,
it will get stored as access.
The only thing I would say potentially
in kind of kind of in defense of some of
these other sugars is that things like
maple syrup, honey, they are sweeter.
So potentially you could
use less potentially.
But that's probably the only thing I
would say. So otherwise that for me,
whether you're um,
using table white table sugar in it and
your cake or whether you're using honey,
it makes no difference. It's still
a cake. Enjoy it, embrace it.
Because actually there's nothing wrong
with having cake or dessert every now and
again. And that's kind of what I
want to get across. I don't have,
I get really cross when
I see people using, uh,
having a Brownie and there'll be,
it's brilliant.
It's really healthy for me
because not only is it sugar free,
it's also gluten free and it's
like it's still a Brownie.
It still gives you the same amount of
energy is still going to use and the body
in exactly the same way. I'm actually from
my point of view, if I want a Brownie,
I'm just going to be a Brownie.
Simple as that.
Similarly plant based milks.
Now I get a lot of grief about plant
based milks because people seem to think
that I'm like, you know, a real uh,
a real Nazi against them.
The only reason I struggle with plant
based milks is because they are promoted
in the wrong way.
There's nothing wrong with using alma
milk or milk or hemp milk or whatever you
want to use if you prefer the taste,
but don't kid yourself that you're going
to get the same nutrients as you would
from cow's milk. That's the only thing I
would say. So I'm not anti any of them.
You know, I, I, you know,
I would probably say that actually for
some people the taste of almond milk is
better than cow's milk.
They prefer it. Great,
but don't kid yourself that you're
going to get the same nutrients.
This is particularly I find with with
athletes because obviously when it comes
to working in within the performance
athletes that I work with,
milk is such an important recovery drink
because it's the right composition of
carbs and protein.
So if they then think they can recover
in the same way with almond milk,
they don't.
And you can see from the kind of table
that if you look at 200 mils of Alma milk
versus 200 mils of Skim Milk, almond
looks just pretty much expensive water.
So what I say to people
is by all means use it.
But don't kid yourself in thinking
it's got the same nutrients.
A lot of the milks,
I say milks,
I have to do this cause it's not really
milk is it? But a lot of the, the,
the plant based milks are fortified
with calcium now, which is a benefit.
Um, I did a talk two days ago
in Belfast and there was a,
a professor who's very big
on her bone health, um, uh,
research.
And one of the things that she came,
what she was talking about is the actually
the intake of calcium is so important
for our bone health. Um, and it
doesn't matter how you get it,
but it's really important if you are
below par, even especially when you're,
you're sort of in your early,
late teens, early twenties,
it can have a real negative impact on
your health and your sort of sixties and
seventies. So it's a really
important area. Gluten,
I've already mentioned gluten. Um, again,
I don't have an issue if
people want to be gluten free,
that's entirely up to them.
Um,
what I find interesting is that when
I first qualified as a dietician many,
many years ago,
nobody wanted to be gluten free.
Like celiacs hated being gluten free
because actually there wasn't an awful lot
of choice out there and the food's out
that they were provided were really high
in fat, really unpalatable and really
high in salt and nobody wanted to do it.
And now it just amazes me that we've got
so many different options that people
want to be gluten free because they
totally believe it's healthier.
There is no evidence in any article you
will read a proper credible scientific
article that is that glute being gluten
free will benefit you if you don't need
to be.
Obviously if you have a medical reason,
then of course you have to follow a
gluten free diet. And I think what again,
I find really interesting is that the
athletes and the clients I work with who
do have to be gluten free, they
really moan. They don't like it.
They still don't think it's fair. But
at the end of the day, um, you know,
I think it's just been highlighted as a,
a kind of a cure for
immune problems and um,
sort of digestive problems.
Often the reason why somebody who goes
gluten free feels better is because
actually when you change
any aspect of your diet,
when you sort of decide you're
going to follow a new thing,
you become more mindful of what you eat.
If you become more
mindful of what you eat,
you get a balanced diet and actually
that's what makes you better.
That's what makes you feel better.
It's not necessarily that you've got
gluten free sugar free or you know, or,
or dairy free. It's actually the,
you just become more mindful.
And that's something that
I hope, you know, is,
is a message I really
want to get out there.
So what is the impact of this kind
of Hashtag eating clean or you know,
what, where does it come into?
How does it become Orthorexia?
So orthorexia as we said is kind of,
it's the obsession with eating
correctly is with eating pure.
And the problem is what might
start off as a really innocent,
I'm just going to try and make myself
feel a bit better. I'm just going to eat,
just kind of talk chart, try
and cut out, maybe, you know,
cut out the takeaways or cuts out,
um,
the biscuits and cakes
every day or whatever it is.
That's fine. We all do that.
I have weeks where I go, oh my
goodness, I've eaten so much chocolate.
I really need to have two weeks where
I don't eat very much. That's normal.
That's not me.
Being obsessive when it becomes obsessive
is actually when you cannot deviate.
So when you start restricting and you,
you basically cannot deviate and it
starts having impact on things like your
social life.
So sadly I see lots of people that come
in to clinic and they think they're fit
and healthy. They think that, you
know, they're doing everything right,
but when they can't join
in with their friends.
And I personally find that really very
sad because for me food is more than just
fuel. Food is about relationships,
it's about networking,
it's about bringing people together. And
it's so important is kind of, you know,
when I sit at a table I can often spot
someone who's got food anxiety because
they're not joining in. They're so fixated
on whether they can eat this or not.
[inaudible] they kind of miss out on
that real kind of connectivity time.
With that, you know, with the people you
want to be with. I know when I'm, I'm my,
my job takes me all over the country
and Archie in different to different
countries as well. And I really miss
out on that time with my friends.
So usually the first thing I do when I
get back into the UK or back home is kind
of organize a meal out with some friends.
I don't care what we're eating,
I'm just there because I actually want
to spend some time with my friends.
But it's just nice to
do over food and wine.
So for me that's a really important thing.
So the problem we have is once you've
got somebody that's following these very
strict food rules,
they follow it because it makes them
feel very safe and controlled. It's,
it gives them something to,
to fixate on and focus on.
But it can also then start to create those
like vitamin and mineral deficiencies.
So if you go dairy free and
you don't replace it correctly,
you will end up with maybe a deficiency
in calcium and also potentially
phosphorous.
These are really important for bone
and teeth and also muscle contraction.
So that can be a problem.
You might if you decide to go gluten free,
you actually might find you
don't eat as much. Whole grain.
Actually whole grains are really
important for the gut biome.
And we all are hearing loads more about
how important the gut biome is and how
that can help your mental health and
how that can also help your digestive
system. But again, people don't realize
that these things are really important.
So from my point of view,
what people set out to kind of think
they're going to be healthier actually
makes them more unhealthy.
And this is what Orthorexia is.
And the problem is they can't step away
from it. They find it too difficult.
So I guess the question is why?
Why do some people,
like if you, if we, you know, we're in
it, we're in a room here full of people.
Not everybody in this room is ever going
to have any issues. Like often people,
like we said earlier, we'll want to, you
read all these new things, you think, oh,
I'll take a bit of that. But I'm
not bothered about that. Like,
if somebody said to me that you can
never eat chocolate again, I'd be,
I'd be completely and utterly
kind of distraught. So, you know,
but that's just,
that's just me.
So why do some people look
for thirdly answer? Well,
it's really about your
personality type. And again,
I'm not saying that everybody has got
this personality type is going to develop
an eating disorder because if I would
always write in the presentation thinking
that's actually me.
And,
and though I need to be really
careful about that, but, but yeah,
we know from studies that
generally speaking tends to
affect people who are high
achievers. They're very determined,
they're very self critical. Um,
they do have an obsessive streak in them.
That's kind of the biggest element of
it. Um, and they're very sensitive.
So what happens is that they
have that kind of, that,
that perfect framework for
where things can go wrong.
And like I said,
not everybody will.
And I think it's really important
that that I highlight that, you know,
you could have all those,
like I said,
you can have a work mostly on traits
and actually be completely fine.
A lot of it is to do about your
experience. So as we go through life,
we all experience different situations,
different circumstances,
and we interpret that in our own way.
It's our perceptions and it's those
perceptions that can then start to create
this very negative mindset.
And that's where you then find that
people are looking for something to help
them make them feel better.
And it's much easier to look
at food training, you know,
some other element is much easy to focus
on that and go, well, if I control that,
I'm going to feel so much better when
actually what they don't appreciate is
that a lot of the issues are going on
with inside them because they're high
achievers because they're people that
are always wanted to do the best.
They never know when that's enough.
They never know when that,
when they've hit that ceiling
and actually they're very,
very bad at accepting failure.
And this is why actually I see this a lot
in athletes because they are that very
driven personality type.
They hate failing obviously because
obviously to be a Olympic or Paralympic
athlete you have to to to kind of, you
don't need, you don't want to fail.
But actually the way I interpreted it
with my athletes is, but you know what?
It doesn't matter.
You learn from every experience.
So if you didn't do that well this
time, let's, let's, let's come,
let's reflect on it and work out what
went wrong and then we try and fix it for
next time.
And these are things I'd love to be seeing
in schools more because this sort of
mindset will develop in a school. This
is, you know, when you're, you're in,
you think about teenage boys,
teenage girls and the bullying and the
kind of chastising and stuff that can
happen.
This is when these things can be set up.
So while that might not be the
time you develop your problem,
if you are somebody that struggles with
your sense of self and your sense of
self confidence,
a lot of these things will be happening
a lot younger and it's only when you get
to a certain point there'll be one
particular thing that will trigger it.
But actually the,
the,
the process has started very early on
and that's why it's such a difficult
condition as well to help
because sometimes the feelings
and the emotions are so
deeply ingrained,
it's really hard to step away from it.
And it's much easier to focus on trying
to eat clean and the pure then actually
deal with that real negative kind of
emotion that's going on inside you because
that makes you feel uncomfortable.
So worried said all threats
in a session with being pure.
And Steve Bartman was the, was the, was
the MD that kind of um, identified it.
So what I wanted to do was give you a
little bit of an idea of what goes on in
the mind, like how it works because
none of this is intentional.
That's the other thing is that nobody
goes out to develop an eating disorder
because it's really a
very miserable place. Um,
but a lot of it is about just not feeling
that you're doing enough. You know, you,
you kind of like, you know, I don't
feel like I'm performing my best.
Well we could probably all say
that at some point. We can,
we already precut probably all
thing we could have done better,
but it's when you start acting on it,
when you think I need to do
something to change it, you know,
everybody else around me is so great
and it's when you do that constant
comparison. And I always say
to again, people I work with,
especially the younger teenagers
that I tend to work with,
there's a lot of comparisons.
And that's another way social media can
really come into play is that, well,
they're prettier than me. They're, they're
more successful than I am. They're,
you know, they've got, it looks
like they've got it all. Um,
I'll tell you funny story
many cause actually I went
through something like that
very similar yesterday but I'll tell you
about in a minute. But um, it was um,
but the problem is you can never compare
yourself to anybody else because we are
all unique. We are all individuals
and there is nobody else.
There's nobody else like me out there.
But I don't think there is a,
but there's nobody else like me. There's
nobody else like yourselves out there.
So comparing yourself to somebody
else is just a few tower way of making
yourself feel worse.
You can only actually
compare yourself to yourself.
So whenever I start to doubt things,
which is quite often I will stink. Well,
compared to a week ago,
I've now achieved this
compared to a month ago,
I'm on a power and that's a much more
kind of acceptable and more Cook Self
Compassionate Way, I guess of, of
looking at it. So the problem is though,
when you don't feel good enough,
you're searching for something to make
yourself feel better. And often it does.
You know, in, in Orthorexia it's very
much about, well, if I eat better,
I'll feel better. We've all heard Evan
and we and we see all the books, you know,
eat this and you'll glow or do this
and you'll have loads of energy.
We all see it.
And of course we buy into that
because we're looking for an answer.
The thing is the answers within us,
because until you accept yourself
and be comfortable with who you are,
it's really difficult to move forward
from this. And this is why when you,
if you do notice these traits or
these symptoms or these kind of,
these emotions in people you
care about or even in yourselves,
please try and get some help early on
because actually the longer you stay in
this cycle,
the more entrenched these food rules
become and the more impact they start to
have and the harder it
gets to step out of it,
the harder it gets because the anxiety
of stepping out of it is just too
difficult to bear.
So the way I tend to kind of describe it
is that you're almost sitting on a box
of emotions.
It's like you're sitting on it so that
you don't let any of those negative
emotions come out. You don't want to
deal with them is like, absolutely.
When you soaked go through recovery,
you do have to jump off that box and
you have to let the emotions out,
which does mean you sent tend to
start to feel very uncomfortable.
Now I suffer with anxiety massively.
The anxiety I felt as I came off the
chip and walk to the Google offices.
I cannot tell you I, I'm I, you know,
I do really struggle with anxiety but
I've learned to manage it because I know
that it will pass because it does pass.
But it's very hard if you're somebody
who never allows herself to feel it
because you're constantly worried
about what we're going to be awful.
It's going to catastrophic cause
that's what the, the anxious mind does.
A cactus cat tracker
catastrophize is everything.
And so you don't want to do that.
But actually the only way to move
forward is to be comfortable with the
uncomfortable.
Similarly,
when you challenge negative
behavior with behavior,
that's when you change. But it's all
very, it is difficult. It's a long,
long process.
So
obviously when it comes to Orthorexia,
if,
when I'm working with people is trying
to help people understand that healthy
eating is not just about
what you put into your body.
It's not just about what's
on your plate at one time.
It's actually about the collection
probably over two to three weeks. So,
you know, you have a few bad days, so,
right, it's not the end of the world.
It doesn't mean you failed. It doesn't
mean you're a bad person. It's just,
you know,
it's a bit busy.
It's Christmas or it's
birthdays or actually you've
gone on holiday, that's okay.
It's fine to relax because the norm is
that you normally probably eat really
well most of the other times.
And then it all balances out.
So I try and actually really educate a
healthy attitude to eating rather than
healthy eating is actually a
healthy attitude to eating.
And I just think, again,
when we're teaching in schools and,
and kind of even in universities
where this is a really big problem,
that's what we should be teaching and
educating people is not always about,
you know,
the kind of the wheel and this is what
healthy eating is actually about the
attitude because that's what is
going to help people move forward.
So my final slide really kind of is that
the biggest thing is trying
to be comfortable with who
you are and it really is
about self acceptance.
And for some people that takes time
and actually takes a lot of inputs.
So majority of the people I work with,
I work alongside a psychologist
or a counselor because
the two things need to go
hand in hand. Um, some people can
do it themselves, some people can,
can make it, can turn
it around. But majority,
I'd say probably 90% of
the cases I work with,
it definitely needs both kind of
nutritional and psychological element and
sometimes more psychological
than nutritional.
Any questions?
Yeah,
thank you very much. So it
was really interesting. Um,
I'm going to kick off if that's okay.
So you touched on it earlier about the,
the younger generation
now as sort of adults,
I feel that we can make a bit of a better
informed choice and kind of research
and the media and things but
with children and kind of um,
I don't know,
secondary school age for example.
How do you think the best way is to
talk to her about their diet and to make
sure that they can make those educated
choices and then they're not being
influenced by the media?
I think one of the biggest things is
teaching them through, through food.
So you know, one of the problems
we have is that when you're in it,
like you look at secondary school menus
and things and they're not very good or
they're not sorts of comp, they're not
foods that maybe they're familiar with.
And that can be a real problem because,
I mean I've done workshops with young
athletes and we've done practical
workshops where I've brought things
like macro and avocado and things and,
and some of them are like,
well I've never seen that before.
Or what is it like literally
had no idea and you know,
you make them into things that
are palatable and easy to use.
I would never get somebody who's never
had macro to eat macro because I think
that's just quite harsh.
But actually what we did with the
blended it up and we made it into a macro
patty and interestingly,
all the,
all the children that had never had
it, probably only two were like, no,
I definitely don't like it. But the
rest of them were really like, oh.
And they went home and they were like,
I want to have this again.
So I think food needs to be quite a big
part of education in schools because I
think there's, there's a
lot of, it's, it's kind of,
sometimes it's like something that you
should just have to do and you'd have to
give the kids. But actually if we
feed our kids properly in schools,
they'll also concentrate better. We'll
get better productivity because again,
we know that if they don't
eat at lunchtime because
they don't like what they
see,
then they're either eat loads of sugar,
which is going to make them kind of
peak and trough or they'll just skip it.
And the problem then is these are the
things that then start to create this kind
of negative relationship with food.
Because if you do have somebody who's
very vulnerable and they start skipping
lunch because they don't like it,
that becomes a behavior and that
becomes an acceptable behavior to them.
The problem we then have is that can then
kind of go into their other aspects of
their life. And before you know
what you do have somebody who's,
who kind of doesn't
really know about food.
So I think education's really important,
but not just what you
teach in the classroom.
Actually getting in there and and kind
of getting the kids to work with food,
taste, food, try different things.
But equally I think as I said,
there needs to be a lot
more on your sense of self,
especially as a teenager.
I mean,
God is probably one of the worst times
ever when you were a teenager, isn't it?
Because everything's changing.
You don't feel great,
you don't look great and we all know
that you will get through it and you do,
you know,
you do eventually look fine,
but at that point it's really,
really hard and you're so self
critical and I think that's,
that's something I would love to do more
of in schools is really kind of look at
how we promote a positive sense of self
because I don't feel there's enough of
that going on if I'm honest.
What is your opinion on every
diet that is based on calories?
When I went there like a year ago,
I spent three months on having a certain
amount of calories I could eat every
day. Meaning I was waiting everything
that I was cooking and I could only cook.
I could not go outside.
Not it was with like feedback.
Um,
and like taking a step back
on it. It sounds awful. Um,
but I've been there
and I'm wondering like,
what is your perspective on this?
There's like so many ways this
can go wrong. Yeah, actually.
So I actually very rarely talk about
calories when I work with my clients
because you're right, it
becomes obsessive. Again,
if you're working with
somebody who is obsessive,
as soon as you give them a number
or something to fixate on it,
it's what happens. And,
and at the end of the day,
the body is really quite,
um, it's quite an amazing,
it's very good at regulating.
If you, if you, if you let it,
it will work for you really well.
And that's again,
another big message I will say to people
is that if you just listen to your body,
it actually does tell you what
you need when you need it.
It's just that we've lost the art of
doing that because there's so much,
there's so much information, you know,
like, like for example, the sugar stuff,
everybody's trying not to eat sugar
because we've heard how bad it is for us.
But actually there are times when the
body and the brain can only work on sugar.
And so if you deprive yourself,
if you start to restrict
yourself, the body, we'll,
we'll kind of work against you.
So what I often find is when
people severely restrict
their calorie intake less
than what they need,
now,
everybody in this room will have
a very different requirement.
But when they restrict their
carer less of what they need,
the problem you then have is
that when food becomes available,
the the body will try and eat to
access because it will say, well,
hang on a minute, I don't know
when you're going to feed me again.
So I'm going to take on as many calories
as I can that then then set up this
real negative cycle of,
Oh my God,
I've just eaten so much and that
it restricts again, and, and,
and actually what you need to do in
these situations is regulate your eating.
So I tend to educate people on getting
the correct balance of carbohydrates,
proteins, whole grains, fruits,
vegetables at mealtimes and snacks.
I'm not anti snacks.
I always have to eat every three hours,
otherwise I fall apart. So, you know,
I'm not anti any of those things. Um,
but it's right for you as an individual
because if you are somebody that say
doesn't x does exercise an hour a day,
your requirements are going to be much
higher than somebody that just sits at
their desk all day long.
And I think this is where we do get
some problems because we as Dietitians,
we talked very much about
moderation and balance.
And of course that's really boring.
It's not sexy. It's not exciting.
It's just a dull word and it is.
Um,
but balance is about what's right for you.
Now I have to be careful because
I don't get people saying, yeah,
but I don't need to eat sugar than ever.
Cause that's what balance is for me.
But that's not what I mean.
Balance is when I say that it's actually
about giving your body what it needs,
but also allowing yourself
to have the things you want.
Because when you suddenly go,
I do want that,
but I can't have it.
You set up a whole new mindset going
on almost like a deprivation cycle.
So it can go one or the other way.
You can either you end up people who
would just want that food and that's all
they can think about and they're
going to just eat loads of it.
Or The opposite side of that is
where it becomes a cozy anxiety.
So I think in your case, from what
I hear is that it became quite an,
and you know, if you step even one
calorie over what you were meant to have,
it became,
became a problem or it cause you anxiety.
Should we say not cook made a problem.
Now this is why also I don't like,
I don't like truckers. I don't like
the online food truckers because one,
it's really difficult to get the right
thing of what you're eating and kind of
make it work.
The other thing is how does that tracker
know the actually today it might be the
actually depending on,
on what's going on for you hormonally,
depending on what's going
on for you mentally.
Actually that day you do need a bit
more. The truck, uh, can't tell you that,
but your body can.
So when I reeducate people,
it really is about helping
them to see that eating is,
should be fun and enjoyable. And actually
the balance is kind of very much,
my principal is very much 80% of the
time I try and eat as well as I can,
which does mean that if I then wanted
to have a glass of wine or pudding or
chocolate, then I can and I
don't worry about it at all.
And that I would use for anybody whether
they're doing read loads of exercise or
whether they're not because you can,
it's, it's proportional to what you do.
Does that answer your question?
It does.
Hi. Uh, I have a question about
what you talked about too earlier.
You kind of made reference to sugar and
how your body doesn't actually know if
it's coconut sugar, white sugar, but
is there something in the science,
and I'm asking you as a can nutritionist,
is there something in the science of
how your body actually metabolizes that?
Cause you do see that some sugars are
processed by your body differently,
such as raising your glycaemic
index, for example. Yeah.
Could you speak more to that? Yeah,
so yeah, I mean obviously some, yeah,
some do have a slightly
different glycaemic index,
but if you look at all the sugars
that we've been exposed to,
the differences my minute,
because at the end of the day they are
all simple sugars so they all affect your,
your, your blood sugars in
the same way. So um, so yeah,
things like honey for example might
have a slightly left glycemic load than
table sugar,
but we're not talking enough to make
the difference that we're being,
we're being told that. I think that's
the thing that it's really important to,
to understand is that the,
the messages were getting about being
sugar free and only eating honey and only
eating maple syrup, et Cetera, et cetera.
Actually then they're not significant
enough for it to be that to make that
change.
I have one more question.
Sorry,
I'm going back into your 80 20 rule,
but she just spoke about is there a
danger and people creating morality around
food. Then being like, oh, this is part
of that 20 or oh this is part of that 80.
I can eat freely for it.
Like do you see that that could also be
a kind of session or something like a
trigger in itself?
It's really good question.
I've never seen that because I
don't ever really spell it out.
It's kind of how I tend to,
I don't sit there going,
oh well I've eaten really well
for 80% of the day to day,
so now I can have my piece of chocolate.
I don't do it like that.
I kind of look at it overall.
So I tend to sort of know that
actually I do that naturally.
I don't have to think about,
it's kind of just what I do. Um,
so when I work with people,
I very rarely use percentages or numbers
because I know and then that becomes
obsessive and we kind of move away
from that. It really is about,
it's actually more about
that attitude to food. The,
I try and really work on
that kind of behavior change.
Um,
I think just
to go back to your
question about calories,
like when I found really
interesting about, um,
calorie restriction is that my
flatmate does it, and anyways,
it's a whole thing. But, um,
she will have her a certain amount
of calories for the day and then, um,
but she'll eat whatever she wants to make
up those calories. So I might eat way,
way, way more calories than she had, way,
way more, but more calories. But it'll be,
you know, through, you know, lean
protein and whole grains and whatever,
whereas somebody else might need way less
calories, but it could all be crisps.
Um,
so I,
what I find really interesting is like
the idea that when you restrict yourself,
you know,
we talk a lot about this stuff that you're
not getting the nutrients you're not
getting,
but is it,
does it also work the other way that you
might be getting too much of something?
Like people who aren't eating any
sugar, dairy or green, you know,
they're obviously not
getting those things,
but are they getting too much
protein and too much, um, you know,
other nutrients that,
because they're trying to make
up for what they're not eating,
like almost too much of the good stuff.
Is that kind of possible too?
I think.
I think the whole thing about balance
is that obviously if you increase your
intake of any other food group,
you would display something else.
So one of the things I really struggled
with when I'm working with athletes is
because they're trying to be healthy
and they're eating loads of vegetables.
They don't get enough carbohydrate,
they don't get enough energy in to be
able to perform because they're trying to
be good. And so, so that's
what I mean, like, you know,
it's kind of trying to get that balance
for everybody as an individual. So yeah,
you're quite right. Because
the thing is, again,
everybody's body will always be
trying to reach energy balance.
So no matter where you're at,
whether you're at the weight you want
to be or whether you're not the way you
want to be,
your body will always be working towards
getting energy balance to basically
maintain where you're at.
So that's why often when you do decide
to go on a very restrictive diet,
you can probably do it two or three days,
unless you're very extreme and obsessive.
And then you suddenly go to,
I can't do this anymore because
I'm just exhausted and an eye,
I'm hungry and I'm going to eat
that burger or whatever it is.
And you almost go the opposite extreme
because the body is always working
against that. It's trying to
keep you alive. Remember that,
that that's what the body's innate
thing is, is trying to keep you alive.
So when people do restrict calories,
it will slow down or the processes.
So the thing I see a lot is it's
those silent things you don't see.
So for example,
when somebody is on a very restrictive
diet and they restrict their calories,
the body slows down the digestive system.
So that can have a real,
a real impact on how your
body works in that respect.
It will, in females, it
will reduce estrogen.
So menstruation will stop because of
what he's going, well, hang on a minute.
I can't,
there's no way I can fall pregnant and
we produce now because there's not enough
energy in the system.
So it doesn't actually affect your weight.
And that's what's really interesting is
because the body will actually slow else
down to keep you alive. So it will,
you'll find that you can't concentrate,
you get cold, you know, you can't, you,
you can't really think straight.
It was all those different things.
You can't sleep. That's a big one. Um,
and that's something that people don't
always realize that actually when you
restrict your intake,
the body is doing everything it can to,
to kind of work against it so quickly.
One thing to pick up on though is
really interesting is that you're right,
some people don't change
in weight and they,
they stay the same and they
might not eat the best way.
They might literally make up their
calorie through Mcdonald burgers or,
or whatever. Um, their choice,
but that's not good either.
And that's not what I'm promoting either.
You know,
it really is about if
you eat the right things,
if you base your meals around wholegrains
and complex carbs and lean proteins,
you will feel full, you
will feel better. Um,
but that also means there is then room
for those little indulgences if you want
them. I think that's kind of the
message trying to get across.
Hi. Hi. And then we talk
about alternative milks.
What about something like goat's milk?
Is that as good as cow's milk or is that,
yeah,
I mean goat's milk
is fairly similar in composition
to cow's milk. So if I'm honest,
when I work with somebody that can't
really realistically can't have milk,
just just has a lactose intolerance or
a dairy intolerance or dairy allergy,
then you have to find them
something because you need
to get the calcium in. Um,
some people, goat's milk, we'll work,
it comes down to the protein or the,
all the sugar in the milk depending on,
on what the problem is.
So for some people, goat's milks fine.
Sheep's milk, good for other people.
Even those, there's so much crossover
with the proteins that if they are,
if it's that particular
protein that they can't digest,
then you have to find another alternative.
So in some cases it's Sawyer,
but we also know there's 40% it's for
people with severe dairy allergies,
there's 40% crossover.
So a lot of people that can't
have dairy can't have Sawyer.
And that's where it becomes problematic
because also then you're looking,
then you do end up looking something
like almond or, oh, um, and I said,
I don't have a problem
with people doing that.
But what annoys me is the man marketing
that it's on par because nutritionally
it's not.
So you just have to make sure that you
get your nutrition from somewhere else.
That's all.
Okay.
I have a lot of friends who swear by
intermittent fasting just eating two meals
a day and they're just
starving for 15 hours.
And that's something that I don't believe
in and I don't feel in the right place
to tell them that they're
starving themselves.
But do you have any specific
advice for this area?
In a lot of the ideas you say kind of
contradicts that this is good for you.
So yeah,
again, intimate and fasting is one
of those ones that's been really,
it's been around for a long time,
but it became its heyday probably a
couple of years ago with the five two and
you know, and and that kind of thing. I'm,
I'm going to say I do use
intermittent fasting in some athletes,
but not in the five to,
because I don't believe in two days a
week where you eat only 500 calories
because your body is just
not in a happy place at all.
But what I do sometimes do for athletes
who were knee to particular body
composition or or wait and it's
just giving it is giving them a rule
unfortunately, but it helps them. You
do it for a very short period of time.
But what we do is,
is actually the intimate and foster and
where they eat for eight hours a day.
So we say between 12 and eight
and then they'll have 15 you know,
they'll have like the 16 hours of fostered
because we know scientifically that's
quite a useful way of
helping athletes meet weight.
But with anything I do like that it's
monitored and supervised and it's only
done for a very short period of time.
So with your friends doing the kind of,
if they're doing sort of
two meals a day and, and,
and that's all they're doing for start,
that's not intimate and fasting,
that's just fasting because intimate
and fast and would mean they do
intermittently. So they'd have
some days where they, well,
and other days where they
eat very restrictive.
I think what's interesting is that when
you look now at the data that's coming
through,
the people that were very big advocates
of the five two are struggling to
maintain it. It's not sustainable
because you then have two,
maybe three days a week where
you can't actually focus.
You can't actually contract.
You can't be productive. Um,
and that because your body
won't be on 500 calories a day.
So it's hard when you've got friends
and you're watching them and you want to
say something. Um, and I
think the only way you can
sometimes do things is, is, is,
is give them some sort of
tangible data. Like, you know,
did you notice that you
made a mistake there?
Or did you notice that you haven't got,
you're really tired or you're actually
really irritable and it's not much fun to
be around. It's, it's, I mean, you have
to be careful how you say that, obviously,
but, but it's that kind of is
that kind of thing. I mean with,
I mean they're often the
opening conversations I have
with a lot of my clients.
I don't go straight in there and go,
you've got a problem with food.
It's very much about asking those open
questions like, what's going on for you?
Like, why are you following that?
What, where, where's that come from?
Because it's really important to hear why?
Because that's something that they feel
really passionate about and you don't
want to sort of kind of belittle.
You want to encourage them to open
and talk to you. So as a practitioner,
building trust with my
clients is the first step.
And then after that you can start to
then kind of really tackle some of the,
the kind of what's going on for you.
Cause you'll probably find the, again,
there's a reason why your
friends are doing that.
If they are trying to maintain a certain
weight or be a certain way or look a
certain way, where does that
stem from? What's that about?
That's kind of how I'd go about it.
And Yeah.
Any more questions from anybody?
No. Thank you so much for coming in.
We really appreciate it.
Um,
when he's gonna be staying in signing
copies of her book as well. Um,
and also joining us up in the cafe.
So if you'd like to purchase a book,
please do let us know and she'll sign it
for you. Thank you so much for coming.